now the labor leader sakistama has
unveiled his five missions for a future
labor government promising to restore
the ambition of the country and stop
what he described as the current state
of sticking plaster politics we'll just
take let's look at the key pledges that
he made this morning he says he has five
missions for the UK to secure the
highest economic growth in the G7 to
make Britain a clean energy superpower
with clean electricity by 2030. to build
an NHS fit for the future on crime the
labor leader pledged to make the streets
safe and on education he said he wants
to break down the barriers to
opportunities for children at every
stage let's listen to a little of what
he had to say earlier
every region and nation of the UK must
be heard
but we have to come together
National missions for National renewal
the fastest growing economy in the G7 a
clean energy superpower public services
that lift us up
a mission-driven government that will
end sticking plaster politics
we'll unlock the pride and purpose that
is in every Community will give this
country its confidence its hope its
future back now is the time for us all
to be part of something bigger and to
say with one voice why not Britain
[Applause]
that's secure's plan for the government
let's just compare it to the promises
made by the Prime Minister Rishi sinek
he says the conservative government
wants to halve inflation grow the
economy and reduce debt plus he's
promised to cut NHS waiting lists and
stop migrant Boat Crossings the channel
let's get more from our political
correspondent Joe Pike who joins us now
from Westminster Joe we do sometimes see
these pledges being made it isn't an
official Manifesto can we hold kirst
armor to what he's saying today
I think we can but they're pretty
long-term pledges and there isn't a huge
amount of detail they're not necessarily
that comparable to what Russia sunak is
doing because of course his uh people's
priorities as he calls them are
priorities for right now uh this year
wine and government was kirst armor is
talking about in some cases two terms of
a labor government of course he's not
going to be in government
um that soon people expect an election
next year perhaps before the summer or
perhaps after so you may be looking at
about 18 month wait even if polls are
correct and remain sort of where they
are there wasn't as I say a huge amount
of a detail here there was that one
significant Pledge on having the highest
sustained growth in the G7 it's
ambitious but it is deliverable because
of course we know the only bit of the
um G7 forecast to shrink in 2023 it is
the UK I thought aside from putting out
these broad policy areas he wants to
focus on I think Mr key was perhaps a
road testing some sound bites that we're
going to hear a again and again and
again over the coming months he talked I
think at least four or five times about
sticking past a politics something
people he said were bored of and want to
end and also spoke of having a
mission-driven government clearly this
is the early steps of a general election
campaign Manifesto and I think this is a
sort of realization on Labor's part that
kiosama has been the critic in Chief
throughout Boris Johnson and Liz truss's
brief Premiership and now he needs to
really explain what he would do
differently of course far more detail
will come in the coming months on the
three pages he's not talked about three
missions he's not talked about as well
as further detail especially around the
economics because I think at this stage
in the Electoral cycle not being that
not having a clear idea of what the
economy is going to look like at the
next election Rachel Reeds had a chance
in particular is not keen on making two
significant a list of commitments in
terms of the attack lines from the
conservatives well actually they mirror
really a lot of the questions we heard
from Joe journalist in the Q a after
speech especially around issues of trust
in particular on Jeremy corbyn a
changing position there on brexit too
this is the view of the chairman of the
conservative party Greg Hans
AMA had no new policies today he's never
made a pledge that he intends to keep
he's changed his mind on everything from
a second EU referendum through to a
private sector involvement in the NHS
through to tuition fees he's never made
a pledge that he intends to keep
so this is the start of a drip drip
process on Labor's part a dripping out
bits of a policy I suppose they would
argue they have now got the sort of
skeleton argument for a Kia salma's
prospective Premiership we'll have uh
the detail the meat in the uh coming uh
months a different series of emphasis uh
to the conservatives Richard tunak has
focused on ending the small boats
talking about immigration whereas
kierstama seems to be in these five
missions talking about a crime in its
place not much talk from a labor party
of immigration today but of course Jen
that could change in the coming weeks